the opening scene features a US movie
director named Eric who arrives in
Cyprus in order to film a documentary he
goes to the famous hotel Gula which
appears to have a tragic history Eric is
accompanied by his wife Sophia who is
born and brought up in Cypress the
couple is received at the airport by a
tour guide named Anna who briefs them
about the place she claims that there
are plenty of materials which Eric can
work on such as sea serpents mermaids
myths and legends of ancient gods as
well as ghosts she also reveals that
hotel Gula has been abandoned for almost
two decades and the locals are terrified
to go near it as they believe that it is
cursed however the hotel is now
purchased by a wealthy couple named
Frank and rosemary and is currently in
the process of renovation upon arrival
Eric meets with his crew members a
videographer named Jennifer and a
soundtech Christine while exploring the
hotel a bag of cement mysteriously falls
from the top nearly crushing the crew
members they look up but find nothing a
Miss as a result they dismiss it
thinking that it happened by mistake or
Bugs Bunnies just being a little
up there again in the meantime Sophia's
attention is grabbed by an ancient
picture depicting violence that's
nothing she hasn't already seen working
in the film industry a short while later
she is approached by her father Bruce
who will be working with them as the
host of the show the two are Overjoyed
to see each other after a long time
later on Eric and the crew members have
a conversation with the hotel owners who
informed them about the hotel's history
according to the couple it was New
Year's Day 199 90 and the 53rd Monday of
the Year something that rarely happens
there was a party and everything went
well but the food was poison due to
which every single guest died this
resulted in a big Scandal and a
highlevel investigation but nothing ever
came out of it at of Agony the owners of
the hotel committed the unthinkable
since then the locals consider the place
to be haunted despite the horrific
history they decided to buy the hotel as
they believe it to be a good investment
and there are no paranormal activities
recorded hearing this Bruce suggests
that they try something new by creating
their own ghost for the show Eric
doesn't like the idea at all but the old
man is confident that the audience will
love it the lowest common denominator
just loves being lied to following this
Eric and Sophia head to their rooms on
the fifth floor to get some rest just
before entering the room he is startled
by a sudden appearance of two female
concierges Who Stare at him in a creepy
way during the night time we also see a
young girl walking along the corridor of
the hotel shortly after Eric Hears A
Sound outside and gets out of the bed to
check but it only turns out to be his
wife walking in her sleep he hurriedly
runs towards her and grabs her just
before she jumps off the balcony Sophia
then snaps back to her Consciousness and
returns to her room maybe take a bedroom
on the first floor the next day Eric and
Sophia have a meeting with the show's
producers Dom and Pat who seem excited
for the shoot after a brief discussion
about the show the couple heads back to
the hotel on their way Eric apologizes
for past mistakes expressing his regret
for for prioritizing work over their
relationship it turns out that the two
had lost a baby in the past and since
then Sophia has been feeling depressed
however she assures him that she is fine
now and tells him not to worry later
that night Eric is working on his
computer when he is approached by Anna
she hands him a master key that can
activate all doors and elevators in the
hotel she also hands him a file
detailing the history of the place
mentioning its association with tesu a
weather God Anna explains that locals
used to worship tesu and sacrific human
bodies to appease her according to her
Tash shub averted a world-ending
catastrophe by defeating his own serpent
pet meanwhile Bruce comes to Sophia to
inquire about her state of mind she
confides in him about her uneasy
feelings regarding the place as she
always senses someone spying on her in
addition she also thinks that there is
something off with the hotel owners as
they are always wandering around the
place in a creepy manner despite her
reservations Bruce assures her that
everything is fine and that there is
nothing to worry about afterwards the
crew initiates their work opting for a
new horror theme as suggested by bruce
for this they dim the lights and
transform one of the hotel employees
into a ghost Bruce then addresses the
audience and declares the exploration of
the haunted hotel he leads them to the
staged ghost and Fs fear once the
recording concludes All crew members
including the producers seem to be
satisfied with the content prompting
them to proceed with a second take I
don't think that's how that works but
okay at the same time time Sophia is
suddenly flooded with memories of the
tragic day in 1990 when she witnessed
the guests succumbing to food poisoning
one after another this makes her feel
very uneasy causing her to collapse to
the ground she regains her Consciousness
after a while but she still appears to
be mentally Disturbed the hotel owners
seemingly unperturbed offer her an
unfamiliar liquid asserting that it will
help her calm the nerves Eric is
suspicious because of its bad odor but
they claim it to be a herbal drink
following this Eric takes her to the
room for some rest but she is
continuously haunted by several
nightmares she then confides in him
about how she can feel an evil presence
around her however Eric brushes off her
concerns saying the place is perfectly
safe and it's going to make us a lot of
money so shut up babe on the other hand
Anna is showering in her room when an
unknown masked pervert in Black sneaks
in hearing a noise she walks out to
investigate but the man hides in her
closet after getting dressed she heads
to Eric's study table to review the
script for their next shoot there she
gets alarmed to find a list of the
victims of the tragedy and hastily texts
Eric when the ladder does not respond
she rushes toward his room to discuss
the matter however the masked man
intercepts her on the way and drags her
to an elevator he then pulls out a knife
and stabs her multiple times resulting
in her death after this he drags her
body out of the elevator and takes it to
the basement in the meantime Jennifer
and Christine are at the hotel lounge
reviewing the footage from the earlier
shoot during this they hear an unusual
sound sparking both curiosity and
confusion in them the two then decide to
investigate its source despite being in
the middle of the night armed with
flashlights a camera and a microphone
they Venture into the dark basement via
the elevator as they progress the
mysterious sound grows louder and louder
at one point of their exploration they
are startled when the objects around
them start to fall inexplicably sensing
an eerie presence the two hastily
Retreat to the elevator Jennifer gets
inside but the elevator door automat
Ally closes leaving Christine behind in
a desperate bid to save herself
Christine hides herself behind a hot
pipe accidentally burning her own face
oh not long after a ghostly figure
materializes behind her which scares her
out in a state of panic she runs away
only to fall into an underground water
tank she is even more terrified when she
finds the dead body of Anna floating in
it before she can comprehend the
situation a hand emerges from the water
and pulls her down ultimately leading to
to her drowning sometime later Eric is
awakened by his phone's vibration and he
finds Anna's message summoning him to
the lobby urgently he then heads towards
the lobby but comes across Bruce instead
the two look for Anna but do not find
her anywhere perplexed Eric returns back
to his wife and moments later he
receives a call from Jennifer who
frantically explains what happened
sensing the urgency of the situation he
leaves promising Sophia that he will be
back soon shortly after his departure th
and Pat break into the room seemingly
with some ill intentions seeing them
Sophia runs out of the room only to find
the same two concierges with knives in
their hands this sets her in panic so
she races towards the elevator however
her Escape is cut short as she gets
apprehended by the hotel owners on the
other side Eric Jenifer and Bruce
Venture into the basement in search of
Christine shortly after Frank appears
out of nowhere so Bruce decides to stay
with him and have a drink together Eric
and Jennifer then continue with their
Quest until they stumble upon a peculiar
wall using an axe they break through and
uncover a hidden old tunnel on the other
side the duo begins to explore the area
and soon a shocking Revelation unfolds
an old photograph from the year 1880
featuring Frank and rosemary this
discovery prompts them to realize that
the hotel owners are not real believing
that Bruce is now in danger they rush to
his Aid reaching the previous location
they find only a cell phone which Eric
identifies as Sophia's but before they
can make sense of the situation Eric is
dragged Away by a group of masked men
while Jennifer is attacked by Pat amidst
the struggle Eric somehow manages to
grab a spiked coil and uses it as a
weapon to take down these men
simultaneously pad is on the verge of
killing Jennifer But Eric shows up just
in time and chokes him from behind right
then the two concierges appear prompting
Eric and Jennifer to run for their lives
escaping through a secret underground
passage they come across the hotel
owners who have inexplicably grown very
old Eric inquires about Sophia and
Christine but Frank response with an
ominous smile just then the concierge
arrives forcing them to continue with
their escape a short while later the two
lock themselves inside a store room
unaware of the fact that Dom is already
inside he stabs both of them with his
knife getting them to the ground as he
prepares to finish Eric off Jennifer
somehow manages to get up and stab Dom
from behind she then tragically succumbs
to her injury leaving Eric alone in this
Rescue Mission despite his injuries Eric
persists in his search and eventually
locates Sophia lying unconscious on the
ground he tries to wake her up but at
the same time a ghostly figure launches
a sudden attack on him regardless he
manages to fight back and stab the
figure with a pointed Rod wounding it
severely here it is finally disclosed
that the ghost is none other than tesu a
mermaid I I knew it Eric perceives it as
a threat and proceeds to finish it off
but Bruce stops him from doing so he
warns that the death of tesu will result
in the death of the Sun and ultim
destruction of the world despite the
warning Eric chooses to take the risk
that's a that a boy Eric and stabs the
mermaid to death upon witnessing this
Bruce becomes deeply Disturbed so he
pulls out a knife and commits the
unthinkable Bruce was as gullible as his
audience in the aftermath of this event
Eric carries his unconscious wife out of
the hotel and brings her to the beach as
he attempts to wake her Sophia's eyes
suddenly widen revealing that she is now
possessed by a supernatural Force she
stares at the Sun which slowly turns
black indicating the end of the world
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching